[Music]
football it's a 360 degree game there's
no padding there is a high risk involved
in it because it is a full contact sport
and yeah you really can cop it from any
angle but we're pretty tough and we get
straight back up from toughie gws's
first goal i'm khloe malloy and i'm a
women's footballer
let's go girls
[Music]
afl or the australian football league is
best described as a combination of rugby
football and soccer i think if you ask
any australian it's a really big deal it
defines us it's a part of our culture i
think everyone has an afl team that they
support
my uncle played football for collingwood
so i grew up watching him and i
immediately wanted to do it
back when i was a little girl i actually
played football for three to four years
but then there's that drop-off that a
lot of girls have
because there is no pathway into a
women's sporting career
in 2017 a women's league was officially
introduced
good stretch from the all australian
the afl women's changed the path of life
for me that i never thought i'd have
great work in the contest from claude
lloyd it's brought out the little girl's
dream that i had back when i did play
football
i think the afl women's is breaking down
a lot of barriers that once existed
amongst women in sport no matter what
race what sexual identity you are it
really doesn't matter and anyone can
play
some people just don't agree that women
should be playing football so that's
probably a challenge that i face and
that the whole league face as well
the best way to react to all the
criticism is just not to react at all
and keep doing what we enjoy
one hope that i have is that if any
little girl or boy clicks on the tv they
know full well that that's a sport that
they can go into no matter if it's being
played by men or women
[Music]
you